well hey everybody welcome to the latest
edition of just getting started right
here
on westwood one podcast i am your humble
host
rich eisen we've had a great run over
the first month plus of this podcast
matthew mcconaughey and damon john
soledad o'brien last
couple have been phenomenal all over the
map if you will pop culture and
obviously real life with
harlan cobin and dr anthony fauci if you
have not
heard any of those episodes please do us
a favor download them and listen to it
after you've listened to this one with
the one and only
gary vaynerchuk if you've never heard
gary talk
you clearly have never been on instagram
or twitter or
any social media and uh if you have
heard gary talk
if you do know what gary's all about
well
here's the deal you're going to learn a
lot about yourself you're going to learn
a lot about what we
are trying to accomplish here together
you and i
on this podcast just getting started
about
figuring your way through life that has
been turned maybe upside down over the
last year
figuring out a way to follow your dreams
figuring out a way to
put aside any concerns you have over
trying something new or even yes
succeeding at it
this is right in gary vaynerchuk's
wheelhouse
he is an entrepreneur he is somebody who
has
been all over as an angel investor in
pretty much every company you've ever
heard of
he owns his own media company he owns
his own sports agency his own
wine company i could go on and on
and joining us here on just getting
started is uh somebody who i'm thrilled
to be able to call a friend
uh someone i've known for quite some
time and uh and then when i met him i
felt like i'd known him for even longer
he is none other than best selling
author and owner of uh
many different ventures including
vaynermedia of which
i just want everyone to know i'm part of
as well gary vaynerchuk how are you gary
i'm well rich thanks for having me on do
bet thanks for doing this
so uh you're perfect uh as a for a guest
for this gary not just because you're
on many podcasts but this podcast is
about people's origin stories and
and how folks can glean
something take something portable from
somebody's beginnings and
you also uh in your remarkable social
media platforms
give so much terrific advice to so many
people who clearly need it right now so
let's
i guess get started with with how you
got started
is is it as simple as you getting
started with
just being a kid in your household when
did you know
that you had some sort of ability to
uh figure out business and
go go from there gary you know i was a
soviet immigrant
that uh first came to queen's very
humble beginnings you know seven eight
family members in a studio apartment in
queens
then we moved for two years to dover new
jersey
uh and then pretty quickly we moved to
edison new jersey where my real
childhood happened
very quickly in the first couple of
months of being in edison new jersey i
became a jets fan
uh within the first year of being in
edison ninjas that first summer because
i moved in very very late august right
before my first grade
school year and by that first grade
summer so call it nine months later
eight months later
i was very active that first in between
first to second grade summer which just
seems crazy my my little guy's in second
grade
but you know i was very
real about lemonade stands i was very
real about you know ring i mean i mean i
was really out there i would find like
a t-shirt or like a pen in my parents
house and literally go outside you know
i'm an 80s baby so just walking out of
the house at 3 30 in the afternoon after
finding something in
the living room or in a drawer and then
just
ringing people's doorbells in the
neighborhood seemed very normal
you know by today's standards kids
aren't allowed to go outside so
you know i i definitely
did things six seven eight nine sh you
know
snow storm comes shovel snow for five
bucks or a dollar or a quarter um
wash cars which i don't think is a very
super
common kid thing but like literally hose
buckets
you know soap ding dong can we get three
bucks to wash your car
i did a lot of that and then probably by
9
10 10 80 for 1985
probably giants won the super ladies 11
uh 86 11 is when i probably was like i'm
a business
man like yeah because 86
giants winning the super bowl i remember
mcconnell that right off the tip of the
varsity yeah
yeah i remember that i remember that
play very vividly because i remember
drawing a version of it in study hall
the next day that monday and trying to
sell that picture
for 50 cents and i remember
that being the era where like the
thought of business
and that's when baseball cards really
started to hit the first time
right uh in my life and you know
that's they say and then the following
year at
between 11 and 12 years old i was
literally going
to baseball card shows and making deals
buying and selling with grown men so
you know it was very quick there in that
five six year four five six year period
in the early 80s mid 80s new jersey
just you know i probably deep down feel
like i'll probably make like a bronx
tale like movie about my life one day
sure and i and that will be the era i
probably most focus on the
early 80s wonder years my version of it
and that's so that's what i remember
that was my origin of like i'm a
business person and these bad grades are
going to be okay because it's not good
i know the world's telling me i'm going
to be a loser but i don't believe them
because i'm good at this thing and that
seems
real to the grown-ups and i'm gonna be
okay so
where did you get that from where did
you get that
i guess want to or drive dna
you know i think you know my father's an
entrepreneur my both my grandfathers
spent time in jail in russia you know
very cliche very common to be
jewish in the soviet union and find
yourself in jail because the whole
country was run by the black market
anti-semitism was ingrained in eastern
european culture
um and this was post you know my
grandfather's
rolling the streets post-world war ii
were a lot of blame and so
you know they were very entrepreneurial
you know i heard stories from uncles and
people that came from the old country
and so dna it's not like i read a book
or had or watched a garyvee video on
instagram you know
this was just like my chemicals like no
different than i'm sure
somebody picking up a basketball or or
picking up a microphone and singing or
just starting to draw
i yearned for the idea of
hard manual labor i liked work i i still
to this day
feel that i probably slightly over work
i mean even
right now right it's 10 p.m on the east
coast
when i'm recording this with you yes you
know i admire you and like you and want
to really support this project
but it's just still in me at this point
that work ethic is a variable i i've
gone away
from a lot of my early content talking
about the variables of hard work because
i called it hustle
i think hustle in modern times the last
two three years
has been manipulated into meaning
something negative which is overworking
yourself and getting anxious
and so i've tried to be more thoughtful
of using the word work ethic
but to this day i struggle
in in thinking about how one achieves
things that they want to achieve without
a real commitment to work ethic i do
think it's a lot easier when you love it
right um but i you know i i definitely
have always
felt my chemicals make me want to put in
that work
and it's obviously very difficult to
manufacture that
but there are some people out there and
again i i'm
a follower of everything that you say
like so many other
millions of people gary and i do see
that
you know you do give very unvarnished
uh advice to people who are wondering
how do they get to where you are again
that you're a kid from new jersey who
did have something born
in you but it does seem like that there
is
some sort of uh brainwave
that you have that people feel they can
tap into
is is there something there is
gary do you think or not i do which
feels weird to say i do
but now as i'm older i'm like wow i have
a lot of
off the beaten path variables i had
an immigrant mother who had two other
younger children than me
who grew up in the soviet union who
you know punished me every report card
but didn't push me like every other
immigrant parent that like grades were
the only way out
and celebrated my accomplishments
you know early on in athletics because i
was the best baseball player in third
grade but by sixth grade
by six that was a tough one by the way
talk about you know why i love sports it
teaches you real quick literally
all-star starting pitcher in
10 at 10 years old and by 13 retired
because you know listen you know speed
i don't know if you know this but as
things progress rich speed
athleticism strength and power all start
to play
hand-eye coordination and grit
determination and deep knowledge
got me to legendary status up to about
right at the cusp of double digits eight
nine ten hall of fame bound
but then those other variables that i
still wish weren't variables
uh took over but um
i was in a rich i'll give you the answer
i was in a cocoon and i think
what i'm replicating with my content is
really an homage to my mom
she created an insular framework
of mentality for me that
makes me feel unbeatable you know i
often say
i'm working on a new book that'll come
out in the winter and it's
it talks about the emotional ingredients
for success and happiness
that i from one man's humble subjective
point of view along the way
and i think it rears its head more in
business than people think and i think
by the way i think it rears its head in
sports i do not think that
organizations get lucky like i think
there's a reason
if you look at 50 60 or windows there's
orgs that do better than others
i think it and and gives me great
confidence once i take over our jets
rich that
i will be able to bring this to the
table so make sure you're hungry you
know
you're healthy and you know because i'm
a turtle it's gonna take me some time
but once i get there we'll get to work
but anyway um she
created a cocoon i never struggled with
peer pressure
i never struggled with self-esteem i was
always kind
i really loved people i did the right
thing i had the right intent
i put in the work i had humility and
accountability
uh but i had ambition and confidence and
i had all these things and
and the world was small it was me and my
family
i loved everything that was going on
around me but it carried no weight
my teachers say i'm going to be a loser
which many did it was a less politically
correct world in the 80s
it didn't bother me my friends wanted me
to drink alcohol and i knew my mom would
be upset if i did
and they said well you're not going to
be popular if you don't didn't bother me
like nothing could ever penetrate my
dome
and in a lot of ways when i look and
separate myself from my content i'm like
huh
i'm just trying to create this little
world the small little pebble on the
internet
where people can come and have a
conversation with me around perspective
that has treated me and not just me
when i really look under the hood of the
people that i admire
who are happy and that's a huge word for
me rich i think
one of my great hopes is before i'm done
as somebody who
people are attracted to the way i
communicate
as i continue to build you know one of
the things i sometimes i'm disappointed
about
is that i love business and that i'm
good at it
and that what seems to be at the
forefront
is this entrepreneurial success when i
have this incredible passion
to change the narrative of success
and focus it on being content and happy
and building a legacy and being
admired and appreciated for your actions
not your accomplishments and and
that's what i think my mom and dad did
for me and i
kind of almost feel this version of
guilt and gratitude
to give it back what you're seeing is
the manifestation of an incredibly
self-aware individual who realizes
everything that people cheer for
is more of me being the byproduct of dna
and parenting and circumstance and what
that does is it actually makes me quite
humble what i mean by that is when i get
love
and i get a lot of it and i get all this
cheering
the way my brain hears it is great job
sasha and tamara vaynerchuk
you know like great job the american
dream you know great
job uh you know accountability and not
entitlement great job not spoiling kids
like i don't hear it like i'm like what
did i do like to me when vaynermedia
gets stabs
when like my doodling when people were
like oh you can you know i'm starting to
doodle a little bit like
when that feels i don't know why that
feels like i but like when people say
you gary are great you are special
you've done [ __ ] i'm like
my brain just goes just so proud of my
parents
today's episode of just getting started
is brought to you by netsuite
if you're a business owner you might be
making running your business harder
on yourself than necessary stop paying
for multiple systems that don't give you
the information you need when you need
it and ditch these spreadsheets and all
the old software you've outgrown
now is the time to upgrade to netsuite
by oracle the world's
number one cloud business system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control over your financials
hr inventory e-commerce and more
everything you need
all in one place instantaneously whether
you're doing
a million or hundreds of millions in
revenue save time and money with
netsuite
join the over 24 000 companies using
netsuite right now
let netsuite show you how they'll
benefit your business with a free
product tour
at netsuite.com eisen so schedule your
free product tour right now at
netsuite.com
eisen that's netsuite.com e-i-s-e-n
now let's get back to garyvee
[Applause]
i hear you too gary you know because i i
i think of my folks quite a bit whenever
i'm doing something
you know um on tv or succeeding and
i don't like you know smelling my own
[ __ ] to be honest with you you know what
i mean like it did
you can really get bogged down in that
sort of stuff
and and and the one thing i'll i'll
share with you gary you know when i
remember when we first met
i met you know with you and your brother
and um reid bergman who's been my guy
for a long time and is now part of your
vaynermedia world and this was at the
draft in dallas
and we had breakfast and you know i
learned
real quick how you're you're you're so
lightening fast in breaking down a
situation
and boiling it down into the emotional
language that someone can understand
where you told me to
own my own show and you told me you got
to own your own stuff and
and you know i i kind of knew that but
hearing it from you kind of crystallized
it for me
and the thing that really hit me is you
told you like you you know you got kids
you got a mortgage
it will take some guts for you to
basically just you know stop doing what
you're doing you know
all all you guys on tv you know you got
your contracts and but you got your
mortgage
you could take some tough i don't i
don't expect you to do it
like but you kind of talked my language
like right on the spot
and i you know i respected that because
you and i just met
you know what i mean and it just
i i i guess the simple question how do
you do that i mean
so many people how how do you how do you
because i think that's what so many
people
respect about your your you know your
your work and how you say it and
obviously when you're
you're talking to people in person
pre-pandemic and looking forward to post
pandemic that's what people
react to how do you do that gary
i know i was i was gifted with empathy
it's how my brain works i sit down and i
listen you know it's so funny i'm such a
loud mouth
that it makes me laugh when people you
know there's nothing more fun
than being misunderstood on first take
and i have all the elements i i actually
rich sometimes ask myself if i self
sabotage because i like being
underestimated
i this is a real we're going a little
therapy session here sure
i go to myself am i a little over the
top because it
allows people to think i'm just a
blowhard
because i so enjoy the unveiling of like
ta-da i'm not full of [ __ ] i got the
chops or i'm
i'm you know i'm not ego i'm humility
like when you know i
enjoy as people get to you know what
feels better than knowing
that the people that know you the best
admire you the most
what's better than that nothing right
when when sally sallypants97 says i'm a
jerk because i said patrick ewing is
better than david robinson on your show
or you know like that's you know i don't
like that because i want to be friends
with everybody and i wish they
understood the context of like kind of
like the sly
jokeness of it all but i'm okay with
that because we don't know
each other if my cousin bobby said i was
a piece of [ __ ] behind my back that's
devastating
um to answer your question it's empathy
i
really i thank you i mean i started a
wine brand had a very successful
business that i sold to consolation
brands
with my with two former interns think
about how that feels where i'm getting
to the gray hairs where i can take
interns to being
multi-million dollar partners you know
um
i named that you know my life's work was
the wine brand i called it empathy
because i realized
that i really appreciate you telling
that story and the way you asked that
question the authenticity behind it
it's a [ __ ] gift i i'm so grateful
for it it's so nice
it feels nice to me i'm like thank god
like i meet a person
and immediately my brain goes into what
can i do for that person how can i help
that person
you know let me listen to that person
and you know it makes people laugh
sometimes when i go on podcasts and go a
little deeper they're like this [ __ ]
guy you don't listen
because on my own podcast and even on
youtube i interrupt
i'm fat you know my brain breaks a
little bit i go too fast i get too
excited i'm always anxious about running
out of time i enjoy it i like
banter more than interview i like you
know like
like the like hanging with your boys at
dinner you know yelling about his
bud web better than mugsy bugs that's my
jam so it doesn't always play in a
podcast where you're supposed to play a
little bit back and forth
so people think i interrupt and i don't
listen what they don't realize is
i listen so much that i don't even need
the per
this is so unreal to say and i've never
really said this this blatantly
i don't even need people to talk rich i
believe in psychics and all sorts of
weird [ __ ]
not because i believe in it actually
because i kind of like don't but i have
to believe in it
because i almost know what somebody's
gonna say almost every time
like i already know if i'm in it with
them
i'm like i know i know and that's why
i'll go and i appreciate i
man i love you you're right i remember
it now too very vividly
i go to people talk baloney like rich
you can do it you're going to make
millions
i go into rich you have a guaranteed
salary that i'm sure you and your wife
and kids you're living your lifestyle
like i'm empathetic
i'm not you know and so i get very
practical but i'm also ambitious
and optimistic so that level of
practicality along with ambition and
optimism is a very unique jux position
of pulling at opposite sides
which creates a little bit of a
different variable and then you got a
highly intoxicating communicator
spitting it and it creates this
different kind of enigma
dan it's it is something that is you
know i'm i'm hoping people will hear
this
and can take it in and maybe use it in
their lives too
um and that's that that's what i wanted
let's talk about that for a second rich
because i want to do that too instead of
just like
who are you at right so
one thing that i definitely was
portraying i'm sure in that meeting
because now i'm really recalling it
pretty well too
i also like thinking about downside so
let's help everybody here rich
when somebody's 22 years old they're
like hey i want to become an espn
announcer or i want to be on bar store i
want to
start facebook or i want to whatever and
you got 70
of people under 18 wanting to be an
influencer or youtuber at this point
which is
self-employment around your own
personality
one thing i remind people is that's
exactly what you should be doing at
21-27
yet your parents in the world and the
system is telling you to get a job and
now it's time to grow up
meanwhile you know this rich both you
and i are old enough now
we're still youngsters thank god but
we're enough in our lives that realize
you know 21 to 27 is a good time to do
risky behavior
you don't have kids you're most likely
not
married if you really have a big ass
dream
you are willing to sleep on your buddy's
couch with six other people and living
like [ __ ] pigs
your body is more capable of eating dog
[ __ ] food
for 50 cents a meal it's actually
logical to be high risk high reward
see the world if you're hyped out or if
you're curious or your photographer want
to see everything
start two companies try to become you
know the next rich eisen or
the next mark zuckerberg or sarah
blakely
and the whole world tells you at 22 you
just went from being a complete
belligerent maniac in college
to hard turn be a [ __ ]
responsible grown it's crazy and then
there's another layer which is there's a
lot of parents who want to subsidize
their kids post college financially
which leads to a very unhealthy
resentment
and like wild i mean one of the scariest
things to me rich is parents paying for
kids at 22 and beyond
for both parties parents have
underlining resentment if you're really
poking prod
and kids start to feel like they can't
do it without their parents help and
they become entitled
so for me my big dream one man's
humble point of view is 22 to 27 is very
high risk
but hey kid you got to eat the [ __ ] with
it you can't be
high risk and mommy and daddy's buying
equinox memberships uber drivers
and like you've got a fancy [ __ ]
apartment like i think if you can get to
that place
where you're 22 to 28 high risk but
you're on your own two feet and whatever
that is
there's something very healthy there
those you know so that's
that's a version of what we talked about
which is like
truth practicality and looking at a
situation
slightly different than the conventional
wisdom right now which also is what
leads me into not being
a fan of college for everyone and not
being a fan of college for a lot of
people
not just like the random person or two
i'm not talking about
zion williamson or mark zuckerberg i'm
talking about
if you're a kid and you're going to go
into 65 000
into debt with a piece of paper that
doesn't get you anything in 2025
because the world's moving too fast for
the university and
and schooling system in america these
are new conversations that we have to
have
we have kids right now who are playing
video games at 12 and 13
who should be playing more video games
not less because they can become
professionals
you know so like there's different
things going on and
parents almost always come from a place
of fear rich
almost always because they love their
kids and fear
and gonna use rich eyes in terms here
fear is
prevent defense and i don't like prevent
defense
rich especially now especially now with
all the offensive rules in the nfl
you're dead you're dead well
you know i and i had the novelist uh
harlan cobin on a couple shows ago gary
and we talked about fear being a
blockade
for a lot of people trying for that
dream trying for
the swing for the fence when they're not
maybe age 21 to 27 when they're
little later on in life that even fear
of obviously failure
but sometimes fear of what next if there
is success how do you follow it
up what do you do to keep going so what
what advice do you do
or let's start with this do you think
the fear of that there's a fear of
success that people might have that you
could
counsel them on or you just think that's
a whole bunch of man
i got it no no no no i think the reverse
i think
i actually have an incredible
fascination with fear
two reasons one the version that you
just brought out
really tickles my fancy because it's
completely predicated almost always on
other people's opinions which drives me
crazy
are you like you're gonna really live
your life though you've
you've won the 400 trillion to one
lottery of having a human life
and now you're telling me with this
miracle
and miracle i'm not talking doug flutie
boston college rich
i'm talking a real miracle like and
you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna listen to your neighbor
who's gonna make fun of you if you have
to move out of the town because your
dream failed and you have to live in a
[ __ ] of your house
you're going to listen to your mom your
your best friend
your spouse even which is the intimate
relationship like you can't
you're going to have resentment you keep
like you can't let other people's
opinions
have so much weight you have to be
compassionate you have responsibilities
that's a different thing
i'm talking about opinions if i lose my
dad's gonna be like see
[ __ ] knucklehead always was a
knucklehead like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that's one number two there's a
different thing that i think about with
fear
i despise leaders
that lead with fear because it's
extremely effective
and i think it's short-term effective
and so when i think about coaches
political leaders
and a whole lot of where i see it
businesses
where the boss or the manager or the
owner
leads with fear cult of personality
sort of thing yeah yeah and and and by
the way both versions obviously we've
had the extreme versions of politics and
sports where we've seen it really go
awry but even just like subtle things
like
you know what's so funny though the
over-the-top versions
like a like a bobby knight right that
plays with me differently
believe it or not because it's so
transparent the one that i really
struggle with
is the ones that are cute about it like
you know you have an employee take
advantage of and
you can see they're about you hear
whispers that they're about to ask for a
raise
and you say things like you know we're
gonna have to cut some people's jobs
this week
just on the way to the coffee what
you're you see what's you see where i'm
going rich
fear i i'm very visceral to fear i
[ __ ] hate fear
i hate it i hate it and i hate the word
hate
but fear [ __ ] with me it does a lot of
bad
and i do believe that fear there's two
words that i think will change a lot
before you and i die hopefully in 60
years
i believe that fear will be rethought
and talked about differently
and i think intuition rich will be which
maybe is a good thing to talk
about in tandem i think we have gone
through a very scholarly
stay in a box black and white century
and what we're seeing right now with all
the disruption rich in the last 12 15
years
i think we're going into a different era
of gray
not the obvious emotional intelligence
doing it different
and i think one of the things that's
going to emerge as the winner of that
era
is intuition i think we have over pushed
people to not trust their intuition
you know that you know like that you're
taught that that's wrong
and i think we're animals and i think
intuition is probably the smartest thing
we got
now you have to be careful that's not
delusion and you're making pretend it's
intuition you're just
you know yeah and so self-awareness but
i i will say that
fear and intuition are two things i
think about a lot
and i think that people really need to
get a relationship with fear
who are you scared of with that you know
it's funny when you said to me i don't
like to smell my own [ __ ]
i always say never get high in your own
supply right
you know not the metaphoric way i easily
deal with people booing and disliking me
because when i get accolades i don't
hear that either
i'm just an athlete on the field
cheering and booing
is irrelevant i've got to play and so
you know i like that you know your
humility is extremely attractive i know
it to be true
i think whatever energy you have around
that
you need to find the same version around
fear because they're actually very
similar
in a lot of ways it's about the idea of
whose
judgment you're worried about if you
lose
yeah it's interesting rich if you can
figure out
who i figured it out for me early on and
then worked at it
the only people i really really
needed to have a relationship in my mind
about that with was my two parents
but very quickly in my early 20s
had that combo with me of like i'm not
gonna live my life
for their prejudgment i'll wait for
their post judgment to the results
so what what do you say gary to someone
who is maybe
our age a little older early 50s
pandemic has just
absolutely turned their lives upside
down and they want to just try and hit
the restart button i mean what
what would you say i start with
gratitude
i say if you're 50 then that means you
probably know somebody who's been taken
because of covet because your parents
friends
god forbid somebody i mean if you're
somebody who's god forbid
had a close one go through this well
then
deploy gratitude thank god you're on
earth
to perspective of time rich people's
relationship with time is really [ __ ]
up
i have a lot of friends who are 50 52 57
63 they'll say things hey gary you're
i'm a i'm like what do you mean that
you're you're [ __ ] 63
you there's a strong chance you've got
30 more i'm like you remember when you
were 33
they're like yeah but it was a trillion
years ago i'm like good
from that moment to right now is the
amount of time you've probably still got
on earth you've got a ton of [ __ ] to do
the [ __ ] are we packing up for right
right and so
what i would say is two things be if you
deploy gratitude
and patience which is a brain [ __ ] rich
for people in their late 40s and 50s and
60s
they're like what do you mean patience
because they grew up in this society
where at like
22 get a job by 30 get married chill you
know this rich like
luckily for the kids now they're pushing
these numbers because they're living
longer
but do you remember like what we thought
about
40 looked like when we were 22 like you
know you're finished that's right i know
you know and now i'm like
[ __ ] i'm 45 and i feel younger i feel
like i'm cooler and younger now than i
was when i was 18 and so
i think that um i think that i would say
perspective around gratitude
and patience and then asking real
questions
what why what why
why do you want to do what you want to
do what do you want to do
do you understand can you how you know
like one thing that blows my mind is
people willing
to live in a house that's way too big
because their self-esteem is wrapped up
in their address
instead of selling that home moving into
a condo
getting back a bunch of money so that
they can take the risk
to start their auto body shop or their
stamp collecting or their new podcast
people are very funny they live in the
rules
who's you know why are you not allowed
to downsize your house
and live more happy why can't you trade
in your
lexus for something more humble like
people are stuck on rules like maybe you
don't have to go to the four seasons
every time maybe you don't fly first
class if you want to be happy
you may have to give up some luxuries or
some ego to put yourself in a position
of happiness
i believe that people's over respect
for outside validation is the single
reason of unhappiness
many of the guests i'll be interviewing
on this show are authors of some of the
most profound books ever written just a
couple episodes we had one on too
i love to read but sometimes i prefer
listening to books on audible so do my
kids
at audible you can find the largest
selection of audiobooks ranging from
best sellers and new releases
to celebrity memoirs languages business
motivation and thousands of popular and
binge-worthy podcasts
audible is great because with their
membership you can listen offline from
anywhere with a tablet or smartphone
with the free audible app
you can even listen across devices
without losing your spot
the new plus catalog makes audible
membership so much more valuable and
gives all members a chance to listen to
and discover new favorites and new
formats like the exclusive
words and music series or a podcast
you've never
dis like the exclusive words and music
series or a podcast you've never
considered before
to get started visit audible.com eisen
or text
e-i-s-e-n to 500-500 my wife might
actually do that
again we love listening to books on
audible in the eisenhower
i think we can all agree that running to
the store has been pretty stressful
lately
and there's nothing worse than
forgetting something on your list and
needing to make multiple trips
shopping for home essentials should be
easy and convenient i think we can all
agree and that's where grove
collaborative comes in
grove is the online marketplace that
delivers healthy home beauty and
personal care products directly to you
with grove you don't have to shop
multiple stores or search endlessly
online to get all the natural goods you
need for you and your family
plus shipping is fast and free on your
first order
so join over two million households who
have trusted grove collaborative to make
their homes
happier and healthier again making the
switch to natural products has never
been easier
for a limited time when my listeners go
to grove dot co
eisen you'll get to choose a free gift
with your first order of thirty dollars
or more
but you have to use our special code go
to grove.co
eisen to get your exclusive offer that's
grove dot co
slash eisen now back to my conversation
with gary vaynerchuk
so in the few minutes i have left with
you gary vaynerchuk let's talk about the
next big thing
that you you see uh i put a video out
um on my twitter feed a few days ago
your appearance in april of 2019 on my
show
and i i put in the copy of the tweet
it's like a ruthie and called shot about
trading cards sports
sports trading cards you're like it's
gonna come back and
the the reason why you said was that the
the sneaker trading market
has only a certain amount of inventory
it's not only
and you know there's more cards and
there are people
our age that will miss that and there's
a nostalgic aspect to it and also
gambling technology the internet so you
saw that thing and and
you did say at the end of uh at the end
of the segment that
you wanted to put it out there on my
show which i always appreciate
so you could look back three years from
now and say you were right and we're
looking back
barely barely less than two years in
your right so
what do you see right now is the next
big thing
nfts it is yeah it is and i know people
you know people's probably at this point
heard it once or twice you've probably
heard about people's art selling for 69
million dollars at
christie's let me tell you why and let
me explain it in a way that i think can
help a lot of people are listening
the macro technology rich is
game changing it's super game changing
uh non-fungible token the digital
tokenization
of something that proves who bought it
people always struggle with that they're
like wait a minute why do i want to buy
a jpeg i'm like the same reason your
kids are buying a hundred dollars worth
of fortnite
skins the same reason 2k and madden are
selling virtual packs to upgrade the
players
the same reason that people want a blue
check on twitter and instagram
to be verified it's called social
currency it has always existed
it will always exist and as we become
more digital
i predict you know i remember making
this prediction with my friends back
in the day and i think it was 1997 i've
been saying it's 1999 but we were
already we were actually still in school
so it was 97
actually now that i look back maybe 98
and i said guys
i think everyone's gonna online date and
my friends made
fun of me rich like you could not
believe because at that point
online dating was reserved for a 400
pound guy
in his mom's basement creepy he might
kidnap you it was
very off the reservation and you
probably remember
online dating in that era but what i
realized was
oh nobody understands that this is now
forever
and as this becomes more normalized and
sure enough and so
what i can tell you right now rich is
the majority of people listening to this
podcast don't realize that in nine years
12 years seven years they will
meet somebody at a cocktail party and
instead of going to instagram or google
and looking up that person
they are going to go to that person's
public wallet
and they're going to see which tokens
and nfts they bought
and when and rich what is going to
happen it's not going to be just like
going to somebody's house and seeing
fancy picassos micassos
but there will be some of that like oh
[ __ ] rich eisen owns this and you know
there'll be some of that
for sure because that's society but
there's gonna be something else
we meet actually let's use us well
obviously we knew of each other
i've been a long long time fan given my
sports love we meet for breakfast
we're doing our pleasantries we have our
meetings but then you know coffee comes
and
last 12 minutes i pull out my phone and
i look at your i'm like
eisen what's your wallet you're like oh
it's at rich eisen so it's going to be
like that
there's you know it's isaac.eath or
whatever the protocols and rules of the
game will be
and i'm just going to scroll and be like
oh bro i got that nameth
token 2. and we'll have that but then
i'll be like wait rich
holy [ __ ] you went to the dave matthews
concert in delaware
in 1997 i was there you've been failing
and because the ticket to that concert
will be a token
or it will say like xyz or you bought
this book like
it's going to show the digitalization of
all our commerce
activities and so which you know which
concerts you went to which super bowls
you went to
you might say gary i knew you're a jets
fan i cannot believe you actually sat
through the whole monday night miracle
because i'm making pretend this is 50
years in advance because when i was in
the monday night miracle rich
and aj and i will tell you this there
was 4 000 people left at the end
i've met 80 000 people personally who
claim
[Laughter]
but what will happen in the future rich
is not only will the ticket that i use
to get in the game be on my tokenized
wallet and it'll show and i'll display
it digitally
but the jets will probably create a
scanner at the end of that game
that i can scan that proved that i
stayed all the way through and
on the blockchain never being able to be
touched by anybody there's complete
digital proof
that i stayed to the end and that will
be cool for our relationship over gary i
can't believe you stayed
like and there'll be these kind of
tokens that are social tokens
access tokens i'll see that oh you
belong to the soho club too because i'll
see your soho club token there
be like hey let's have our next dinner
this it's going to talk for us the same
way pictures talk for us now
it's a major technology now comma this
is huge
big point i believed in the internet the
most in 96 789 and i yelled from the top
of the mountains
but when my friends started buying stock
in 98.99 because they had a couple bucks
i'm like guys
you know i'm you know like gary i'm
doing this like you told me i'm like no
no i'm like i told you the internet's
big i didn't tell you pets.com and etoys
are worth 500
a share i'm like these companies don't
make money
they're you know i'm in the wine
library.com business yet there's still a
lot of people that don't know how to use
the internet
right like not everybody's buying i
think they might be overpriced and sure
enough
as you probably remember march april
2000 all the internet stocks went to
zero
but ebay was there amazon was there for
five bucks 10 bucks 20 bucks whatever it
went down to
and that's what's going to happen rich
with all these nft projects
you know nfts are going to be something
you will be talking about to the rest of
your life
nba top shot crypto punks chubbies
these projects you know uh crypto
kitties
you know uh the the moon cats
uh and then pokemon what you know
waxio's garbage pill kids the nfl is
going to have their nba top shop
ufc has already announced that they have
their nba top shop with flo
and those guys the the nhl
uh soccer and then the human individuals
we've already seen it from gronkowski
and patrick mahomes like i listen even
though he's a pat
he at this point he's a buccaneer i like
a good gronk laugh as much as the next
guy
and i'm really proud of gronk for moving
first
but it's going to be very unlikely that
the value that those gronk nfts went for
are going to stay
here's why rich the supply the amount of
nfts that are going to come out you're
going to have an nft for your race
you know like like you just everything's
gonna be nft so there's gonna be
it's gonna be like this in 1994 it was a
novelty to have a website people are
like whoa
you have a website right now it's just
like oxygen
the same thing will happen with nfts
everything will have nfts
in 20 years the key now is to not
get too caught up in the gold rush the
beanie baby moment and just start
investing in [ __ ]
a lot of it will go down i believe
crypto punks
since it was the first nft project on
ethereum
it's got this legendary status i think
that one goes crazy long term
but do i think over a big correction in
a year or two
or six months that that could even drag
down it could and then bounce back up
like amazon
so that's the macro of it
and when it all comes down to it though
i think
some many people are kind of turned off
by because they don't think they can
afford it
you know the prices that you're hearing
meanwhile
meanwhile yes you're every but
everyone's looking at very small things
that's like saying
well i can't be an influencer because
charlie demilio has 100 million tick
tockers well of course you can 80 000
followers on your honey business could
be meaningful
right you can't buy a beeple for 69
million but i'm just looking right now i
want to actually
give him a shout out i'm just about to
buy one
from from buddha ben i'm literally doing
it right now
literally like i'm about to buy it's
.001 each it's like
nothing it's like a couple it's a
hundred dollars if that
like like you know there's gonna be
there's gonna be plenty of bargains the
problem is
right this second as of recording 99 of
things are going to be overpriced
because we're in that
early the beanie baby stages
gary you the man love you bud i really
uh no i do consider you uh
you know honestly just going back full
circle to that conversation we had in
dallas i
i you know i'm always honest with with
my uh listeners viewers guests as well
literally ten minutes after you were
telling me about you know i've got a
mortgage and i've got
kids and you know people like me don't
usually take this risk but you should i
really was sitting here and said
who the hell does this guy think he is
and then by the end of
by the end of breakfast i was like okay
and then i'm going to my car and i'm
like
wait a minute this actually was
not only made sense but i appreciated
the way you actually put it
and then obviously in the in the ensuing
years i thought to myself that is like
gold you know what to get advice from
you uh i know there's many people in my
industry for sure that
that reach out to you for it and so many
other people do so for you to actually
you know come on this pod and
help uh help me brand it and give those
two cents to people who need it i really
appreciate it gary
i adore you your class sack thank you
for having me right back at you that's
gary vaynerchuk right here on just
getting started
yes sir that's gary vaynerchuk right
here on this pod and when he said
that age 21 to age 27
is the sweet spot to try something new
and go for it and risk it because
you will sleep on a friend's couch you
can go
somewhere and follow a dream and
try your best to make ends meet but you
also don't have the
things that you might have in real life
i don't want to say weighing you down
since i am somebody with kids and a wife
and a mortgage but
i think you understand what i'm saying
is that when you are free
of responsibility to others
and also maybe a bank that's loaned you
money
if you're free from those
responsibilities go for it that's why i
also
wanted to ask about uh an older age
group in their 40s and 50s and 60s if
somebody has to try something new
just get started on something new his
advice for that
but when i was age 21 through
27 that's when i i went for it i mean i
told a story earlier
um in in the uh podcast
previous episodes about having an
epiphany behind the wheel of a car
chasing an ambulance literally chasing
an ambulance while on a
uh filling in for a reporter on the
police beat for my local newspaper the
staten island advance or as we said in
staten island the advance
putting the syllable on the accent on
the first syllable
but um i had an epiphany there
and i was age 21 through 24 i just said
you know what screw it i'm going to go
for it here
and i went back to graduate school i got
deeper into debt which is another thing
that gary talked about that
you know college might not be uh proper
for some because
getting so deep into debt to go to
college
might not be the right path for people
but i i
you know took more student loans out and
i was still having to pay off student
loans to my
you know the university of michigan and
i decided i'm going to go for it i'm
going to
try and get a graduate degree and get a
tape together and
go anywhere i had to go to
just get started on my career and i
i looked in upstate new york because i'm
from staten island new york for my first
job and
um you know crashed on some couches and
definitely crashed on some couches
at northwestern because the last part of
the
um the seminar was in the last part of
the of the year that i was there at
northwestern was in washington dc i
crashed on some couches there
and um i went to reading california
and to get my start for
670 an hour which is what i think i told
harlan koban in the previous episodes
that that's what my hourly wage was 670
675 an hour
and um went to reading california
got my start there and it was a total
out of body experience i'm from staten
island new york the home
of the world's largest landfill that's
now been closed so the mountains i grew
up around were made of garbage literally
and now here i am in redding california
surrounded by actual mountains if
anybody's ever seen the tv show northern
exposure
you know with the jewish guy in the
forest
that was me in in reading california
and i just went for it i went there i
wasn't making much money i certainly
wasn't being able to pay off my student
loans very well
but i just rolled the dice and i just
said you know what
i'm just gonna go for it i'm gonna go to
a spot where i feel like a fish out of
water and try and
make myself the the biggest fish in that
pond
and sent a tape to a headhunter cost me
first class postage that's all it cost
sent it to a three
news and sports um television news and
television sports headhunters and espn
found my tape
and the rest is literally history so
when gary's like you know when you're 21
you're 27 if you're
somebody who's who doesn't have
um much uh on the responsibility
scale for yourself go for it i totally
agree with gary
that's what i did and i want to thank
everybody for listening to this
edition of just getting started right
here on westwood one
we'll see you next week